your very survival
is dependent on a highly complex network
of other species on earth
you can breathe because plants animals
and bacteria regulate the atmosphere
you eat crops that depend on a climate
and a water cycle that is regulated by
forests
humans depend on healthy ecosystems
yet it's humans that have put all of
this at risk
pollution climate change and the
exploitation of habitats
and loss of biodiversity are playing
havoc with ecosystems
[Music]
ecologists have been warning of a sixth
mass
extinction and there's academic debate
over whether that's already happening
what's very clear is the rate of
extinctions is alarming
of the estimated eight million animal
and plant species on earth
one million are at risk of extinction
three quarters of land and two-thirds of
marine environments
have been significantly altered by human
actions
the populations of mammals birds
amphibians reptiles and fish
shrank by 68 percent on average between
1970
and 2016. in short
animals are becoming extinct at the
fastest rate
in all of human history it's alarming
because
human societies basically depend on
their being a diversity
of organisms and ecosystems out there so
the biodiversity crisis presents a
threat
to human societies humanity relies on a
narrow range of species for food and
resources
but those species are themselves part of
a complex ecological web
that can't be sustained without a much
greater diversity of animals
plants and bacteria take tuna
we fish tuna we eat tuna but the tuna
doesn't exist on its own it's at the top
of a huge
food chain microscopic marine algae
called phytoplankton
are eaten by micronectin like shrimp
which are eaten by smaller fish which in
turn are reasoned by tuna
and that's just one chain of a much
wider ecosystem
you need all of the stuff that the tuna
eats throughout its life in order to get
the tuna that you net at the end and
that you serve on a dish
the biodiversity crisis may pose as
greater risk to humans as climate change
but it gets far less attention in many
ways those two crises
are interlinked the largest sink
for carbon emissions is plants soaking
co2 out of the atmosphere
turning it into plant material through
photosynthesis
as we lose plants we contribute
to the climate problem you can't solve
the climate problem
unless you solve the biodiversity crisis
but there is a glimmer of hope an
explosion of new technology in the past
10 years
from motion activated camera traps to
microphone monitors and radio tags
which is helping ecologists to track
measure and protect
life on earth
the global airborne observatory is a lab
in the sky
it flies over coral reefs savannas and
rainforests
gathering data about these vital
ecosystems
i feel like equation 11 could be
combined with equation
10 in the future it's the brainchild of
dr greg asner
a renowned ecologist our airborne
program and our satellite program have
been
deployed to understand how our
rainforests are changing how temperate
forests are changing
african savannas and even tropical coral
reefs
our technology allows us to put together
a picture
of the biodiversity of a region how much
carbon is stored in that region
and the health of the ecosystem overall
it looks like some
relatively younger corals down in here
the data collected can then be used to
create 3d models of entire landscapes
our technologies have advanced over the
last 20 plus years
to include lasers that fire out of the
bottom of the airplane
and those laser beams image the land
surface
that gives us a 3d view of what we have
and we fuse that with another technology
called an imaging spectrometer that
technology tells us the chemical
composition
of the environment we're going to come
up on another dark patch here
right here initially the team's work
concentrated just on forests
but the radical changes in coral reefs
due to climate change and coastal
development
prompted them to diversify their
research
i'm really interested in this one
because it's such a large colony
i wonder how old it is work has really
been focused on
understanding what is happening to our
reefs
you know it's a much harder problem
because
literally it's covered by sea water the
story out there is that all coral reefs
are dying
they're all in trouble but they're not
all dying there's a wide range of
outcomes right now from good to bad to
pretty ugly conditions
our technology is letting us work with
governments work with conservation work
with managers
to understand in more detail what
they've got
it's really the kind of detailed
information that
puts biodiversity into the discussion
into and onto the table
among decision makers
[Music]
from up in the air to down on the ground
there's a huge and highly sophisticated
patchwork of technology
that is monitoring biodiversity all
around the world
and as the tech gets smarter smaller and
cheaper it presents even greater
opportunities
one of the first rules of making a
sensor to put in the field is it has to
be small and cryptic
and easy to hide this tiny device is
helping to protect
endangered species i'm holding in my
hand
one of our trail guard ai cameras and
you can see right away
how small it is it's basically a little
bit longer than my index finger
it's been designed by eric dinistein a
leading expert in biodiversity
technology
but unlike most conservation cameras
trail guard doesn't only track wildlife
but poachers too
essentially trailguard is an ai
infused camera-based alert system
that functions like a burglar alarm for
national parks
it allows 150 rangers to be as effective
as 1500 rangers
poaching is responsible for the
destruction of a number of animal
populations in africa
it's still the largest direct threat to
many of the world's most endangered
species
in the first trial of trail guard in
africa
we were able to detect 30 poachers
representing 20 different poaching gangs
the protection forces on the ground were
able to make significant number of
arrests
trail guard strength is down to machine
learning technology
the ai scans through the camera's images
for poachers
and issues an alert if one is detected
here's a picture of me you can see the
bounding box
around it determines that i'm indeed a
human being
if it was a picture of my dog it would
say
that's not a human i'm going to filter
out that image and not
send it for conservationists ai has
revolutionized the time-consuming task
of scanning through images sound
recordings and other data samples
one of the most pressing conservation
problems we have
in the world today is how do we monitor
endangered species
they're very hard for biologists to
study we can now
use computer vision to monitor the
movements and behavior
of these endangered species like tigers
and rhinos and elephants
but even if every living creature on the
planet could be logged
the data would be useless without
understanding how every species relates
to everything else
one solution could be to develop better
biodiversity models
much like climate models they would
forecast the impact of changes to
ecosystems
but addressing the loss of diversity
will require funding
and the support of governments all the
sensors in the world
are not going to save a species from
going extinct you're going to need
policies and you're going to need humans
on the ground to
affect those policies
yet policymakers response to the
biodiversity crisis
has been slow in 2010 a list of 20
conservation targets
known as the aiichi targets was drawn up
the aichi targets are incredibly complex
incredibly detailed in what they're
trying to
achieve but also horrifically vague
in how they are to be met and what a
measurement of successes
for most of them the result of all of
this is that by the time
the reckoning day came in 2020
none of the targets were fully met
right now humanity is on a trajectory
that's heading off a cliff
all of the technology in the world
cannot compensate if we don't have the
political will
to use that information and protect life
on earth
i'm katrine brahick environment editor
for the economist
to read our report on conservation
technology please click the link
and thank you for watching
you